ich habe mich auch mit dem
koalitionsvertrag einmal mehr
beschäftigt mehr als 100 seiten immer
ein quell der ladung und erbauung und
mir ist aufgefallen dass wir über weite
strecken politik auch für den ganzen
kontinent machen das ist natürlich
äußerst freigiebig
sonntag sind wir ja alle immer ganz
große europäer die drei ampel parteien
ganz besonders und möchten alles nur
noch abgestimmt mit europa tun wenn man
dann aber mal sich die details anguckt
dann sieht das etwas anders aus beispiel
migration da werden anreize in
deutschland gesetzt wir wollen fast
alles legalisieren was im augenblick
eine duldung hat wir wollen neue asyl
tatbestände schaffen und wenn jemand
kommt und keine personalien hat dann
kann er an eides statt versichern er sei
derjenige der er vor zu geben sei und
dann ist das schon in ordnung mit
anderen worten geschaffen in der mitte
europas einen migrations magneten was
wir nicht dabei berücksichtigen ist dass
mit dieser entscheidung im
koalitionsvertrag der druck der
migrationsdruck an den außengrenzen
steigt mit anderen worten die folgen
haben zb die polen an der grenze nach
belarus zu tragen oder die griechen oder
die italiener am mittelmeer beispiel
energiepolitik wir steigen aus kohl aus
wir steigen aus atom aus und hängen in
den europäischen netzen in letzter zeit
musste immer öfter aus der schweiz
beispielsweise oder aus frankreich strom
zugekauft werden auch aus osteuropa und
wenn wir so weiter machen und konsequent
den weg der erneuerbaren energien
beschreiten wird das nicht so leicht zu
puffern sein wir machen jetzt insofern
energiepolitik auch für die anderen
nennen damit die uns auffangen müssen
und wir haben bei der sogenannten
energie taxonomie durchgesetzt dass auch
gaskraftwerke die wir nun als notlösung
brauchen dass die als grün eingestuft
werden obwohl man auch dort fossilen
brennstoff verbrennt das ist putzig aber
ist eine politik die auch zu lasten der
anderen geht beispiel cannabis während
egalisieren cannabis als eines der
größten länder in der mitte europas und
nähmen in kauf dass man in grenzen in
den nachbarländern proben märkte dann
entstehen weil natürlich bei offenen
grenzen man sie überschreiten und nach
holländischen muster dort einkaufen und
konsumieren kann ist das gewollt ist das
abgesprochen haben wir gefragt haben wir
natürlich nicht beispiel finanzen wir
verschiedene jetzt 60 milliarden aus
einem nothilfefonds der nur deshalb
unter den bedingungen der schuldenbremse
möglich ist weil wir als crooner
pandemie eine nationale katastrophe
haben diese 60 milliarden sollen jetzt
in einen investitionsfonds umgewandelt
werden kann man machen finden viele
wahrscheinlich irgendwie eine lässliche
sünde problem ist wir haben über jahre
den ganzen europäern sparsamkeit und
klarheit und wahrheit in der
haushaltspolitik gepredigt wenn jetzt
deutschland anfängt zu schimmeln sagen
sich die anderen gut warum nicht wir
auch mit anderen worten was ich in
berlin beschlossen wird hat auswirkungen
auf ganz europa sollte man vielleicht
darüber reden auch mit den nachbarn
ja da muss ich doch mal einen haken denn
ein passus steht auch im
koalitionsvertrag der mich sehr freut
und der ganz andere richtung einschlägt
und zwar dass geplant ist ein
europäischen verfassungskonvent
einzuberufen und das ist tatsächlich mal
neuer ton und der soll erarbeiten oder
die frage beantworten ob es einen
föderalen bundesstaat geben soll und das
denke ich ist glaube ich eine ziemlich
große frage und die steht auch wirklich
irgendwie an in europa
interessanterweise die csu hat damals
auch gesagt oder steht bei ihnen glaube
ich im programm das wenn das zur debatte
steht und auch wieder kompetenzen
abgegeben werden auf europäischer ebene
dann leuchtet es eigentlich auch eine
volksabstimmung das ist jedenfalls
csu-position das würden wir auch sagen
aber die frage ist natürlich auch ob man
dann kompetenzen auch wieder zurückgeben
kann denn ich glaube wir müssen genau es
in diesen ganzen punkten gedanken machen
wie organisieren wir uns eigentlich in
der europäischen union und lösen die
probleme immer nicht nur allein
punktuell und hoffen die anderen machen
mit oder
notfalls in die röhre wenn ich den
zunächst natürlich interessant zur
kenntnis dass die sie zu den wenigen
journalisten gehören die momentan nicht
regierungssprecher werden wird mit
diesem wissen wir warum
gerade dieser qualifiziert für herrn
habe ich frau bernburg und alle anderen
also tut mir leid haben hier mut vor
fürsten der schule ein einsatz
vielleicht noch zum inhaltlichen dazu
diese dieses die suada die sie jetzt
aufgelistet haben da ist ja das meist
richtig das stimmt aber wir haben jetzt
ja mit der jetzigen regierung nicht mal
der stunde null angefangen und gerade
wenn sie migrationspolitik erwähnen oder
energiepolitik das sind doch alles lücke
die eigentlich die vorgängerregierung
von eingeschlagen hat und war denn jetzt
wir sprechen sie mir vermutlich hahn
aber wahr denn die vorherige
bundeskanzlerin jetzt wirklich die
perfekte europäerin als diese nicht
dargestellt hat sie den absprachen
gesprochen getroffen mit dem polen mit
den weißrussen mit den ungarn ich glaube
nicht aber ich glaube nicht zu meiner
rechtfertigung eigentlich nur sagen ich
hatte angenommen die lektion 20.15
hätten wir gelernt und das war ein
beispielloser wären wir als nation aber
offensichtlich haben wir nicht gehen als
lernendes system ja klar also dazu muss
man tatsächlich sagen wir müssen ja
nicht müssen eine bestimmte fehler nicht
wiederholen was ich was ich nicht ja ich
glaube dass wir dann fehler war dass wir
dort fehler gemacht haben ich will aber
schon 1 nicht im raum stehen lassen
natürlich ist angela merkel eine eine
absolute 1000 prozentige europa in
europa bürgerin
nichtsdestotrotz schützt einen das ja
nicht vor fehlern so und der fehler dort
war dass wir eben nicht mit den anderen
ländern gesprochen haben und der fehler
ist das ist jetzt auch da das ist schon
wieder angelegt hier verstehe was wir
wie wir ändern dinge wo wir wissen dass
viele nachbarn und vor allem die länder
die betroffen sind nämlich die an den
außengrenzen sind einen ganze also eine
konträre meinung dazu haben und das wird
nicht dazu führen dass wir brücken bauen
sondern dass er die die gräben tiefer
werden und der ton rauer das wäre
schlecht da wird im übrigen auch kein eu
superstaat helfen weil das wird man
nicht überdecken können sondern wir
werden bei solchen prozessen er die
menschen verlieren und da muss man
versuchen
nicht ausgeschlossen aber die die frage
entscheidung wieder haben sie gesagt die
entscheidung der grenzöffnung sicherlich
keine die im europäischen rat getroffen
wurde dass das klavier schrecklichen
versuche dann einen verteilschlüssel
einzuführen wenn man schon fakten
geschaffen hat ist jetzt auch nicht nur
als freundschaftlicher akt aufgenommen
worden und witzigerweise tritt die ampel
regierung in die gleichen fußstapfen
kommt geht jetzt vor an und sagt wir
nehmen 25.000 afghanen auf das kann man
gerne machen höher wir haben einen
schengen-raum wir haben offene grenzen
innerhalb europas wenn deutschland diese
leute aufnimmt nimmt ganz europa sie auf
und wenn die verwandten in luxemburg
oder in brüssel haben dann fahren sie
natürlich dorthin war dieser schnelle
ausstieg aus der atomkraft nicht dass
noch größere spaltpilz in europa auch
immer einiges auf der liste wenn wir uns
jetzt sicher entwicklungen anschauen ich
meine heimat atomkraftwerke wissen
praktisch umgeben von atomkraftwerken
weltweit wenn sogar kohlekraftwerke
gebaut und hat gerade beschlossen und
zwei neue zu bauen und die sind 17
millionen leute also wenn es immer heiß
politik ist die summe rückholbare
entscheidungen das ist nicht mehr
rückholbar wir sind jetzt wirklich
draußen aus der atomenergie ob das so
klug war mittelfristig auch für den
umweltschutz ich weiß es nicht weil sie
weiß nicht ob das und nicht rückholbar
sein werden ja also wenn wenn sie
beschreiben richtigerweise das holland
zwei neue atomkraftwerk gebaut das makro
einen wahlkampf darauf aufbauen seine
nukleare energiegewinnung komplett zu
erneuern dann würde ich das jetzt mal
nicht sagen dass das ausgeschlossen ist
natürlich in der bilanz wäre es
natürlich schon bemerkenswert wenn man
das aussteigt und dann wieder einsteigt
denn das ist natürlich auch mit
entsprechenden investitionen verbunden
siemens bei ihnen in münchen ist auf den
atomausstieg in deutschland aus der
gesamten produktion von atomanlagen
ausgestiegen und dabei haben die die
sichersten reaktoren der welt gebaut da
geht eben auch wissen und know how
verloren ähnliches machen wir übrigens
bei der kohle wo wir nicht in der lage
sind anderen ländern bei der säuberung
von schmutzigen kohlekraftwerken zu
helfen weil wir uns im kohleausstieg
dazu verpflichtet haben diese technik
nicht zu liefern das ist natürlich schon
bitter weil da könnte man wirklich um
größenordnung jetzt stattfinden den co2
ausstoß reduzieren
leider sind wir auch da draußen aber sie
brauchen natürlich auch einen
gesellschaftlichen konsens dafür der in
deutschland natürlich besonders schwer
und sie haben natürlich immer noch
fragen die auch nicht gelöst sind die
möglicherweise in der gewichtung mit
tatsächlich der co2
den co2 emissionen vielleicht an
bedeutung verlieren aber das ist eben
die frage endlagerung und was machen wir
mit den abfällen und mit den gefahren
die damit auch verbunden sie fahren
jetzt sie habe neben den superstart
europa angesprochen und ich muss sagen
auch ich liebäugelt damit vor allem wenn
ich auf die anderen weltmächte blicke
und auch glaube dass wir da zusammen
mehr erreichen können wie könnte denn
aussehen wenn er das muss er erstmal der
verfassungsgebende konvent erarbeiten
und die frage beantworten wollen wir
tatsächlich so ein bundesstaat werden
und was würde das erleichtern und dann
müssten natürlich auch erstmal die
einzelnen staaten wieder zu stimmen und
das müssen wir auch diskutieren denn ich
glaube das hat auch konsequenzen wenn
wir wieder kompetenz nach oben abgeben
die frage ist wann kommen die denn immer
wieder zurück kommen die überhaupt
zurück und auch so fragen zu beantworten
muss zum beispiel so eine agrar
richtlinie muss die für die gesamte eu
gelten also haben die bauern nicht im
norden europas ganz andere sorgen als im
süden europas gibt es da nicht auch
klügere lösung sachen auch wieder in die
kompetenz der einzelnen staaten oder
sogar regionen zu formieren aber ich
sehe dass auf jeden fall erstmal um
zurückzukommen auf den koalitionsvertrag
als einen positiven aspekt tatsächlich
das überhaupt so eine verfassungsgebende
konvent angestrebt wird europaweit und
ich hoffe das bleibt nicht nur einfach
eine schöne zeile im koalitionsvertrag
bin ein bisschen
im zweifel mit mir selbst ob ich der
buhmann des abends werden sollte ich
halte von so einem moment überhaupt gar
nichts es wird jahre dauern da irgendwie
auf einen gemeinsamen nenner zu kommen
und den superstart will eigentlich
niemand das rückholen finde ich eine
ganz charmante idee weil auch wieder das
subsidiaritätsprinzip haben und dinge
die dort gelöst werden wo sie auftreten
in den kommunen beispielsweise in den
ländern kann man machen aber wir haben
einen so unterschiedliches
staatsverständnis mich nicht falsch weil
wenn der konvent auch zu dem ergebnis
kommt das ist niemand will dann wird es
das nicht geben aber genau diese wäre
glaube ich muss endlich mal was der
lissabon prozess hat glaube ich fünf
jahre 8 jahre oder länger gedauert man
kann das natürlich immer machen ich
verrichte bloß
es werden dort sehr viele leute über
jahre mit konferieren beschäftigt sein
und
vielleicht ist es zielführender im
europäischen rat in kleinen schritten
voran zu gehen aber große visionen haben
immer auch ihre berechtigung